[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
elizabeth holmes's shocking defense
strategy revealed attorneys for the
former theron ceo say she'll likely take
the stand and accuse her ex-boyfriend
and co of abuse and r kelly's first male
accuser takes the stand saying he was
groomed and sexually abused by the
singer the shocking testimony as another
woman who says r kelly raped her in his
dressing room at a concert when she was
17 years old days after he secretly
married aliyah plus i think that he
thought he had killed me we speak to a
survivor of the infamous railroad killer
her inspiring story of escaping a brutal
attack by a serial killer and later the
accused arsonist on trial i can't get
out
i can't get out opening statements in
the ohio case that left nine people dead
including five children law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin we begin with r kelly's sex
trafficking trial and the shocking
testimony from two accusers the first
male accuser took the stand along with
another young woman
day eight of the r kelly sex crimes and
rico trial began with another jane doe
on the stand addie prosecutor cruz
melendez questioned addie as she
described the single encounter she and a
friend had with r kelly at the budweiser
superfest in miami it was september 1994
when she was only 17 years old addie
described going to the green room with
who she believed were r kelly's
bodyguards cruz melendez showed the jury
the vip pass addy had that day it had r
kelly's autograph addy's name and the
hotel room he invited her to but she
never went to the hotel because after r
kelly played music for the girls asking
them who was the better kisser he
allegedly took addie and forced himself
on her having unprotected sex both girls
ran out the room afterwards but didn't
make a report for over two decades next
on the stand was the first male accuser
lewis who testified under a false name
met r kelly in illinois when he was 17
years old the age of consent in the
state and that r kelly gave him his
number and promised to groom him as an
artist after meeting him at a mcdonald's
the relationship became sexual both
one-on-one as r kelly allegedly gave him
oral sex in his garage with a boxing
ring in it and with others when r kelly
allegedly snapped his fingers three
times for a naked woman to emerge under
his boxing ring and give them both oral
sex at the end of his direct lewis
admitted that he was testifying under a
cooperation agreement that after being
charged with bribing someone cooperating
with the government not to testify
against r kelly a bribe r kelly was not
aware of something the offense hammered
on as they started their
cross-examination
in this trial jane doe won it is singer
aaliyah her uncle and former manager
barry hankerson introduced her to r
kelly when she was just a teen he opened
up this weekend on the ricky smiley
morning show and says he nearly wanted
to kill r kelly when he learned about
the alleged abuse aaliyah suffered
well to be very honest with you
of course i was upset and of course i
had
to really
i had to really
really consider what my reactions would
be
right um
and uh i really found out i wasn't a
hardcore criminal i couldn't kill my
body right so uh
so i just took it you know i'm a muslim
and i just i went to the industry fair
economy
and we just prayed about it
and just resolved ourselves so that god
handled him
joining us today as legal analyst dina
dahl and terry austin dina r kelly isn't
charged with sexual acts against lewis
so how is the jury hearing about these
allegations
you know prior bad acts are often let in
to show you know a plan
motive opportunity we saw that in the
harvey weinstein case we see it in the
robert durst case the judge makes a
determination that this evidence is more
probative than prejudicial because it
can be prejudicial to the defendant
because it may more likely show that
they did something or did not do
something
because of that this his decision the
judge's decision will be appealed if he
is convicted and we have seen cases
overturned when an appellate court
decides that the judge made the wrong
call that the evidence was actually more
prejudicial than probative absolutely
something that all doesn't have to
evaluate and of course there's always an
appeal that comes with cases like this
terry do you think the jury will have
the same response towards r kelly that
hankerson has as they hear more and more
about the allegations against r kelly
i think not only the jury but i think
the public is going to have a similar
response i mean the fact that at first
hankerson wanted to kill kelly that
makes sense i mean this is someone he
cares about as far as his niece is
concerned and he's her manager but he
said he prayed about it he knew he
wasn't a hardcore criminal and he
decided to let god handle it there are
those though that think he was in a
position to protect her and he really
should have seen what was going on so
perhaps he should have been a little bit
more observant as to what might have
been going on around him yeah i can see
the arguments on both sides terry lastly
loses testimony comes from a cooperation
agreement when he tried to bribe someone
to protect r kelly now r kelly was not a
witness to any of this but lewis said
that he did so to protect r kelly does
this help or hurt the prosecution's case
anytime you have a witness on the stand
and they have a cooperation agreement or
they've been accused of trying to bribe
someone that's going to hurt their
credibility in front of the jury but i
think overall it's going to show that r
kelly definitely took advantage of
anyone male female young old the fact
that he thought he could sexually abuse
anyone under his control under his power
so i think having this witness on the
stand even under these circumstances
even with the accusation of bribery that
it's going to at the end of the day
benefit the prosecution
absolutely now there are no cameras
allowed in the r kelly trial because
it's a federal court proceeding will of
course give you updates as we get them
turning now to more top legal news
members of the kennedy family are
speaking out saying they're not
supporting parole for the man convicted
of killing robert f kennedy
sirhan sarhan was recommended for parole
on friday he spent the last 53 years in
prison for fatally shooting rfk in a los
angeles hotel in 1968. the parole
board's recommendation came after two of
kennedy's children rfk jr and douglas
kennedy wrote in support of sirhan's
release but now six other rfk's kids say
they're devastated by the decision and
are hoping for a reversal of the
decision it's now up to california's
governor gavin newsom if sarhan should
be released
in georgia prosecutors say they will
continue to seek the death penalty for
the accused atlanta spa shooter
investigators say robert long killed
eight people in a deadly shooting
rampage in march
six of the victims were women of asian
descent last month long pled guilty to
23 counts for the four murders in
cherokee county in exchange for an
in-life sentence without parole but in
fulton county prosecutors say they're
not reaching the same deal long appeared
in court on monday and spoke briefly to
the judge mr long this question is for
you do you have any objections to the
defense counsel that have been appointed
or the manner in which defense counsel
is conducting or has conducted the case
thus far sir no sir
in fulton county long faces 19 felony
charges related to four murders near
atlanta the district attorney for fulton
county will seek the death penalty for
long's crimes along with a sentence
enhancement under georgia's new hate
crime law long is due back in court next
month for his arraignment
still ahead on law and crime daily
robert durst is back on the stand when
will the cross examination wrap up but
first elizabeth holmes shocking new
defense revealed will a former theranos
ceo take the stand at her upcoming fraud
trial find out after the break
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back jury selection in the
highly anticipated trial of elizabeth
holmes is slated to start this week and
now defense attorneys for the former
theron ceo are hinting she'll likely
take the stand to accuse her former
partner of abuse
what do you dream for
that less people have to say goodbye too
soon to people they love that was
elizabeth holmes in an hbo documentary
talking about theranos the company she
founded in 2003. it was promoted as a
way to revolutionize medical lab testing
but federal prosecutors say it was a
scam a grand jury indicted holmes and
her former boyfriend theranos co ramish
sanibawani in 2018 on 11 charges of wire
fraud and conspiracy to commit wire
fraud holmes is slated to stand trial
first and on her own in a newly unsealed
court document defense attorneys say
there is a significant likelihood that
ms holmes will testify at trial that she
suffered intimate partner abuse by
bowani holmes met belwani when she was
18 and he joined her company her
attorneys now say he exercised control
over her and she was unable to think
clearly at the time of the alleged
crimes an expert for the defense is also
expected to testify about psychological
emotional and sexual abuse suffered by
miss holmes at the hands of mr belwani
in a separate newly unsealed document by
belwani's team his attorneys are calling
the accusations salacious and
inflammatory mishome plans to introduce
evidence that mr belwani verbally
disparage her and went through affection
if she displeased him the filing goes on
to allege that mr bahwani's control
including monitoring her calls text
messages and emails physical violence
such as throwing hard sharp objects at
her restricting her sleep monitoring her
movements and insisting on any success
she achieved was because of him holmes
is accused of defrauding investors of
millions and scamming doctors and
patients they have both pled not guilty
but admit to not disclosing their
relationship to investors
back to break down the latest in the
theranos case is legal analyst dina dahl
and terry austin terry bringing up
intimate partner abuse as a defense to
making false statements what do you
think of the argument
i think it's actually quite a good
defense it's pretty creative if you ask
me intimate partner abuse basically is
just saying that she was abused
emotionally physically psychologically
and it's saying that her ex-boyfriend
was actually the leader in the
relationship even though she was the ceo
and he was the ceo they're saying that
he led her both at home he led her at
work and this is important because the
prosecution is going to need to show
that she had the requisite men's rare or
the intent to commit this fraud they
said they're going to bring experts on
the case and they're going to try to
demonstrate that she did actually commit
this fraud and i think
knowing about this relationship is going
to be very important because at the end
of the day the prosecution is going to
have to show that she knew what she was
doing and that she was controlling
herself and no one else was controlling
her yeah it's all about what she knew
and when i'm expecting a lot of emails
and correspondence back and forth to try
to prove just that as the prosecution
seeks to try to get that guilty verdict
uh dina do you really think holmes will
testify could this be a tactical move to
try to separate the defendants and their
stances in the case as best as possible
i mean very likely you know we know
defendants rarely testify because then
she will open herself to much more
questioning you know questions of her
credibility than she otherwise would if
she wasn't going to be taking the stand
now she's what she's arguing there that
kind of like he made me do it
might require her to testify because it
speaks to really her psychological you
know state and
it's unclear whether or not she can um
prove it any other way and that's a
little bit of a problem with her defense
you know most likely they had staff in
their household did any of them see
anything like this you know were friends
concerned of hers were there emails that
were controlling that she still has if
she doesn't have any other evidence then
i don't think that her lawyers will put
her on the stand because at that point i
don't think the jury would necessarily
believe her and then she's opening
herself up but if she has some evidence
that backs up her claim she might well
have to take the stand to kind of put
that last little spin on her claim yeah
i can see that who else is going to be
able to say yes i did these acts but he
forced me to sounds like coercion which
is a it's a hard hill to climb but we'll
see how that plays out again as in the
case of u.s v elizabeth holmes thank you
both turning now to california for the
trial of accused murderer robert durst
the real estate air is on stand for the
third week of questioning
robert durst is on day eight of
cross-examination under prosecutor john
lewin in court on monday durst was back
wearing his suit a change from his
jailhouse clothes judge mark windham is
urging the prosecutor to wrap up his
questioning saying that lewin has more
than proven robert durst is not a
credible witness in the killing of his
best friend susan berman the defense has
indicated they're also considering
calling an expert on autism to speak
about durst asperger's diagnosis in the
state's rebuttal prosecutors say they
plan to call andrew jorecki the director
of the docu-series the jinx that
interviewed durst before his arrest
coming up on law and crime daily a man
accused of setting three fires that
killed nine people now on trial the
opening statements you don't want to
miss
plus the infamous railroad killer one
woman's harrowing tale about being
attacked by the serial killer how she
lived to tell the tale ahead
[Music]
not many people can say they've survived
an attack by a serial killer but there
are people who have angela levy
introduces us to a woman who nearly died
at the hands of the railroad killer
holly dunn and her boyfriend chris meyer
were attacked by a serial killer on
august 28 1997 in lexington kentucky
holly was fortunate enough to survive
you know
it was a
completely the wrong place at the wrong
time
my boyfriend and i
were at the railroad tracks and
we had been at a party we got up to
leave and this man approached us um it
was complete we didn't you know we
thought he just wanted money
um but he ended up tying us up and
gagging us
he ended up
killing chris and
raping and trying to kill me
miraculously dunn survived the railroad
killer angel matarino resendez he
attacked dunn and meyer on railroad
tracks resendez killed as many as 14
people in several states dunn's
testimony at a trial during the penalty
phase led to his death sentence
that was a very very hard day it was
very hard to face him again even though
i really wanted to do it and i knew that
i wanted to do it it was still super
hard
i think if my family hadn't been there i
don't know if i could have done it
but i did dunn recently told her story
on a e's i survived a serial killer she
also wrote soul survivor a book about
her journey and she founded holly's
house an organization that helps
survivors of trauma
how are you today i'm great i mean you
know
there are still hard days i'm not going
to lie to you and say that some days
aren't still hard the anniversary of the
attack is always a hard day for me i
just know that it's going to be and i do
self-care i appreciate my second chance
at life i know that i could have died
with chris and that i wouldn't be here
telling this story and i feel like i
have to
live a strong life and live a good life
for all of fercendez's victims i
survived a serial killer heirs on the a
e network for law on crime daily i'm
angenette levy
thanks angeannette when we come back
opening statements in the newest trial
on the law and crime network the ohio
man accused of killing nine of his
neighbors by sending fire to their homes
what will the defense be find out next
[Music]
welcome back an ohio man is now on trial
for allegedly setting fire to his
neighbor's homes leading to the deaths
of nine people
stanley ford is accused of setting three
fires in his akron neighborhood from
april 2016 to may 2017. nine people were
killed including five children under the
age of 15. if convicted ford could face
the death penalty ford originally stood
trial last march but a mistrial was
declared due to the pandemic before
court began monday the jurors went to
the three crime scenes to see the houses
in person then prosecutors delivered
opening statements and told the jury to
look to the defendant's own words to
investigators
you're going to hear that the defendant
told
ellis pope that linda lewis was a
vicious guy
that lindell lewis had buddies sitting
on his front porch drinking alcohol
that lindell lewis had prostitutes
working out of the house
the defendant told detective stewart
that the people across the street were
bad people they stole everything they
were bothersome to everybody
they had prostitutes in and out all
night and were dealing in homosexuality
that gloria jeannie hart gets drunk and
does drugs that the people in 719 votes
were not his friends because of his
standards
and one of the guys wanted to see how
long his penis was
finally the defendant tells detective
stewart that tom hugely tried to break
into his mother's house
the defense pointed the finger at other
possible suspects claiming that two of
the victims had unpaid dues to drug
dealers and that there was another arson
in the area unrelated to the defendant
it's not a dispute that there were three
fires set
it's not a dispute that all three fires
were set intentional
and it certainly is not a dispute that
there were nine deaths and since he's
called the folks that would come over to
lindell lewis's house is being rough
around the edges all right i think what
the evidence is going to show
is that there is history of drug use
there is history of drug abuse
there is history of folks at that house
not paying their dealers for their drugs
and you're going to hear about the
conflicts that occur in that house
and you're going to hear about
another instance of arson
separate and unrelated
to what's being alleged here in the
state of ohio versus stanley ford
dina what do you make of the defense's
opening of there being alternative
suspects does the drug dealer did it
defense sound reasonable to you
well i think they better have some
evidence to back that up because that
was some pretty strong victim blaming if
indeed they have evidence to this effect
then you know that's a fairly strong
defense they need to show you know i
mean they don't need to prove it but
they need to create reasonable doubt and
some sort of evidence to that would do
that but if he made such a strong
statement and really has nothing to back
it up he may have just you know ended
the case right there because no juror is
going to want to hear that level of
victim blaming yeah you've got to under
promise and over perform if you do it
the other way around especially opening
statements it could be a deadly result
terry how damaging do you see these
comments the prosecutors opened with can
you see a reasonable non-criminal
explanation for what he described about
his neighbors
the prosecution brian had a very
powerful opening statement it was
detailed he had displays so that the
jury could understand what was going on
point by point and he showed videos and
they were very clear videos it showed an
individual not necessarily
identifying specifically that it was
stanley for but it showed an individual
that you could see setting the fire i've
never seen anything quite like that and
i think it was very impactful for the
jury so i definitely think that it was
strong one slight criticism is that it
contained just a little bit too much
detail and i think sometimes with all
the names the dates the addresses it
might have been a little difficult for
the jury to follow but overall i thought
he did a great job absolutely thank you
both and thank you for joining us here
on law and crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you